guten abend und willkommen zu unserer
corona sprechstunde freut mich dass ihr
dabei seid wann fängt endlich wieder die
schule an das fragen sich gerade viele
schüler auch die die vielleicht
normalerweise gar nicht so gerne in die
schule gegangen sind
seit mehreren wochen wird jetzt zu hause
gelernt und unterrichtet und so richtig
ist kein ende in sicht das ist schüler
eine echte herausforderung gerade für
die die vor wichtigen abschlussprüfungen
stehen
darüber wollen wir heute sprechen mit
kai schmidt erster mathe lehrer und
rektor an einer oberschule in
niedersachsen vor allem aber ist er
bekannt mit seinen erklärvideos auf
youtube als lehrer schmidt ihr könnt
gleich eure fragen an ihn loswerden erst
mal hören uns jetzt aber an was
eigentlich die schüler sagen wie die das
finden dass keine schule mehr ist
vermisse ich wohl einerseits weil die
struktur einfach wirklich fehlt aber
andererseits zahlt auch wegen den
freunden die man hier zu hause natürlich
nicht hat mit dem mal quatschen kann
oder auch aufgaben lösen kann ich glaub
die lehrer wurden auch alle relativ ins
kalte wasser geworfen ich denke ein paar
schlagen sich gut versuchen auch viele
verschiedene sachen aus ich glaube in
einer wohnung mit einem geschwisterkind
dass ich ein zimmer zu teilen oder gar
vielleicht auch zu fünft in einer
kleinen wohnung zu stecken und wenn man
jetzt nicht rausgeht ist so ein punkt
viel konzentration extrem schwierig ich
war ziemlich überrascht dass es
funktioniert hat
natürlich war am anfang ein paar
schwierigkeiten ich wünsche mir dass an
münzen die schule wieder losgeht weil
ich dann steige ich dann wieder meine
freunde sind fragen und darüber sprechen
wir jetzt mit lehrer schmidt kai schmidt
der ist mir per skype zugeschaltet guten
abend mit guten abend
wir haben jetzt ja so ein paar stimmen
von schülern gehört deckt sich das mit
ihren erfahrungen mit dem was sie so von
ihren schülern hören ja das passt ganz
gut das ist tatsächlich so
ich glaube für uns alle ist das eine
neue und ungewohnte situation und ich
glaube tatsächlich
die allermeisten sind froh wenn es dann
endlich wieder losgeht das ungewisse ist
halt dass niemand weiß wann sie wieder
losgeht und wir alle eigentlich auch so
eine nachricht warten
das wollen wir gleich auf jeden fall
noch vertiefen jetzt waren wir aber
zuallererst einmal darauf schauen was
lehrer schmidt eigentlich so bei youtube
macht ganze 500 fast 500.000 verlor hat
er dort nämlich herzlich willkommen bei
lehrer schmidt dieses video ist für dich
kai schmidt ist ober schulrektor im
niedersächsischen städtchen ösen und
lehrer für die vermutlich größte
virtuelle schulklasse deutschlands
455.000 abonnenten folgen seinem
youtube-kanal namens lehrer schmeckt ihr
gemahl nachrichten mit ich bin mal
fakten mit stelle sie vor und lade euch
dann immer mal wieder zur diskussion ein
ich freue mich wenn ihr mitmacht sein
eigentliches steckenpferd ist aber
mathematik wer in der schule nicht alles
so ganz genau kapiert hat der hat im
internet eine zweite chance bei lehrer
schmidt seine videos sind gerade jetzt
seid die schulen geschlossen sind
besonders gefragt kai schmidt ist ein
lehrer der weiß wie seine schüler ticken
auch in corona zeiten also wir haben es
gerade gesehen herr schmidt sie haben
sehr sehr viel erfahrung mit digitalem
unterricht aber wenn man sich ansonsten
so eine republik umhört dann hört man
irgendwie meyer die einen machen
arbeitszettel von den nächsten lehrern
gibt es mails oder vielleicht auch
videos wie halten sie es denn jetzt
gerade in niedersachsen haben wir das
große glück dass gerade osterferien sind
das heißt wir hatten zwei wochen die wir
ja zu überbrücken will ich nicht sagen
die eine herausforderung waren das hat
bei mir an der schule auch mit meinen
schülern so weit ganz gut geklappt wir
hatten aber auch das muss man
fairerweise sagen günstige voraussetzung
wir haben einen schulserver jeder
schüler bei uns hat eine eine e mail
adresse so konnten wir also problemlos
aufgaben verteilen und einsammeln
wer ein eigenes modul für so dass es bei
uns im großen und ganzen
gut lief und viele meiner kollegen haben
dann auch noch regelmäßig
videokonferenzen mit den mit den kindern
aus der klasse gemacht so das ist
eigentlich eine ganz gute betreuung gab
haben sie ihn dabei eigentlich alle
schüler auch erreicht oder gab es auch
schüler die abgetaucht sind die aufgaben
dann auch einfach nicht erledigt haben
ja das gab es allerdings muss man da ein
bisschen aufpassen ich wohne im
westlichsten niedersachsen wie es halt
nur geht und tatsächlich haben wir hier
noch einen internet versorgungsproblem
also wir sind eben keine großstadt ich
bin so eine richtige dorfschule und da
ist es schon auf den letzten metern auf
dem letzten bauernhof tatsächlich ein
problem mit dem internet und auch da
mussten wir erfinderisch sein und im
zweifel werden dann zur not aufgaben
auch per post verschickt tatsächlich
okay die haben sich dann einfach bei
ihnen telefonisch gemeldet also da
musste man sich jetzt keine sorgen
machen sehr gut lassen sie uns noch mal
auf die probleme schauen also 1 habe er
schon gehört nicht jeder ist perfekten
mit internet versorgt was hören sie denn
da sonst noch so von ihren schülern also
es ist man muss immer bedenken es war
natürlich für alle eine neue situation
und tatsächlich was ziemlich gut
geklappt hat ist das heute ja im prinzip
jeder schüler ein smartphone hat so dass
es so irgendein gerät ist eigentlich
tatsächlich immer gibt und wlan ist in
den meisten fällen zu hause auch
verfügbar wenn auch nicht immer schnell
so konnte man zumindest die aufgaben
verteilen in der etwas andere frage ist
dann vielleicht die frage der motivation
und auch der unterstützung zu hause und
die ist natürlich schon unterschiedlich
und das muss man auch bedenken
man hat also diese dieser ein
elternhäuser die da richtig hinter
sitzen und maximal unterstützen um das
inhaltlich auch können aber genauso
haben wir auch elternhäuser die das
entweder zeitlich nicht hinbekommen oder
auch inhaltlich nicht und das muss man
eben auch akzeptieren und diesen
unterschied den muss man bedenken
sie kommt gerade bei youtube eine frage
von johanna und die geht genau in die
richtung wie können weil solch einer
situation die eltern am besten ihr kind
unterstützen und helfen ja also ich
glaube wichtig ist dass man sein eigenes
kind gut kennen muss und es gibt dafür
und das ist in der pädagogik ja immer so
es gibt nie die richtige antwort sondern
es gibt immer nur die richtige
antwort für das jeweilige kind und es
gibt kinder die kamera zu hause
wahrscheinlich gut fordern das ist mit
sicherheit auch altersabhängig genauso
wie das kinder geben die werden sehr
schwer sein zu motivieren und da muss
man einfach immer den richtigen weg
finden
da gibt es unterschiedliche wege die
comdirect noch eine frage hinterher und
zwar drehte sich darum den umfang der
aufgaben der hier als zu hoch
eingeschätzt wird
was raten sie da eltern denn die sagen
das schafft man kennt eigentlich alles
gar nicht also am einfachsten ist immer
eine rückmeldung zum klassen oder zum
fachlehrer dass man da einfach nochmal
nachfragt die frage haben wir uns auch
gestellt das ist ja schließlich auch
eine pädagogische frage wir hatten uns
entschieden für 120 minuten aufgaben am
tag da sind wir in summe so bisher
jedenfalls meine rückmeldung ganz gut
mit gefahren aber auch da sind schulen
sicherlich unterschiedlich vorgegangen
wir wollen außerdem ja auch auf die
prüfungen eingehen da kommen auch einige
fragen hier zum beispiel bei youtube
fragt jemand was raten sie denn dem
jahrgang der jetzt abitur macht ich weiß
sie haben jetzt keine abiturklasse die
sie betreuen aber das ist ja ganz
generell das problem also da stehen
gerade ganz viele schüler in deutschland
von abschlussprüfungen egal welcher form
wissen nicht genau ob die kommen wie wie
kann man sich da als schüler motivieren
zu lernen zum beispiel ja dass das ist
eine schwierige frage ich bin in diesem
jahr auch in einem zehnten schuljahr da
geht es um die realschule
abschlussprüfung und auch da ist die
frage wie gehen wir die sache an und zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt gehen wir erst mal
davon aus dass wir den gesamten fragen
und aufgaben gaben katalog arbeiten
müssen und da fehlen jetzt erstmal zwei
wochen ich weiß nicht wieder am ende mit
umgegangen wird in der regel ist es so
dass man mehr wert hat oder dass man
über den lehrer so diese übungshefte
angeschafft hat und wenn man das gemacht
hat dann würde ich empfehlen dass man in
diesen übungshefte entsprechend arbeitet
die sind in der regel gut aufbereitet
haben sie denn ein paar tipps jetzt
wirklich ganz konkret für schüler wie
die sich zuhause motivieren können wie
man am besten lernt wie man sich das am
besten strukturiert
ich glaube ganz ganz wichtig ist dass
man sich eine tagesstruktur
so erhält also dass man sich wirklich
hinsetzen so was wie einen stundenplan
macht und sagt so ich habe am tag nehme
ich mir 120 minuten vor und diese 120
minuten die ziehe ich ganz fest von neun
bis elf durch das ist dann meine
brotzeit oder meinem schreibtisch zeit
und da wird gearbeitet und ich glaube
wenn man sich da wirklich dran hält dann
ist das zuhause gut für den
familienfrieden aber man hat auch so
eine wisse ja so ein bisschen
fortlaufendes lernen ich glaube das ist
ganz wichtig und inhaltlich würde ich
das genauso strukturieren ich würde also
bei den grundlagen anfangen wenn ich
jetzt im bereich mathematik binden dann
vielleicht wirklich noch einmal die
grundrechenarten und dann die
bruchrechnung dann lineare funktion
alles der reihe nach durch arbeiten und
wiederholen und jeder mache das so wie
das am besten kann entweder mit dem buch
mit aufgaben oder eben auch mit videos
es ist ja alles da kommen ganz viele
fragen dazu ja wann und ob prüfung
überhaupt stattfinden hier wird zum
beispiel youtube gefragt ja genau werden
sie überhaupt stattfinden oder zink bei
youtube fragt was bedeutet das denn
führen den klausur planen zum beispiel
können auch ganze klausuren entfallen
ohne nach geschrieben zu werden
da kann ich zum jetzigen zeitpunkt nur
sagen wir müssen abwarten was das
jeweilige bundesland entscheidet zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt ist mir da noch keine
bekanntgabe bekannt wir müssen das
einfach mal abwarten ich weiß es nicht
wie läuft das denn dann wie müssen wir
uns das vorstellen sie sind jetzt rektor
werden sie dann vom bildungsministerium
informiert also wie es da genau die
informationskette bei solchen fragen ja
es ist also ganz einfach wir bekommen
eine eine e mail aus dem ministerium und
dort das nennt sich bei uns dann erlass
und da wird dann erklärt wie wir das
ganze umzusetzen haben das funktioniert
ganz einfach und in der regel auch
tatsächlich ganz schön und wie wird dann
die info wiederum an die schüler
weitergegeben weil da muss man ja dann
ganz sicher sein dass sie auch wissen
wann die prüfung stattfindet und dann
nicht nachher ein schüler kommt und sagt
ach ich wusste gar nicht dass heute die
prüfung war die mail die ist in meinem
spam-ordner gelandet zum beispiel bei
uns jeder schüler eine e mail adresse
hat schicken wir das zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt an die e mail adresse
parallel dazu schreiben wir auch
elternbriefe wir hatten vorher in einem
elternbrief angekündigt dass wir in
dieser phase die elternbriefe eben per
e-mail rausschicken
dann gibt es diesen eltern blieb aber
immer auch noch mal als pdf auf der
homepage und genau dieses vorgehen
hatten wir vor zweieinhalb wochen also
am letzten regulären schultag genauso
angekündigt und dann in papierform mit
nach hause gegeben
genauso wie auch alle kinder vorbehalte
nicht alle schulbücher mit nach hause
genommen hatten so dass wir einfach gut
vorbereitet worden
lassen sie uns auch noch über das thema
digitalisierung sprechen sie sind daher
durchaus dem vorreiter schon seit jahren
mit ihren videos auf youtube
aber wenn man sich den rest der
bildungslandschaft anschaut ist das ja
nicht unbedingt so glauben sie dass
diese corona krise und auch die
schulschließungen dass die vielleicht
auch da digitalisierungen jetzt einen
schub geben könnten in den schulen
ich hoffe es was kann ich andere sagen
ich glaube das ganz ganz viele und ich
hoffe ganz viele entscheidungsträger
auch in der politik es gemerkt haben
dass wenn wir da entsprechend
ausgestattet sind dass das nicht von
nachteil ist
und ich erzähle das ja schon seit vielen
jahren ich will gar nicht sagen dass
digital immer besser ist das ist das ist
mit sicherheit nicht immer aber im
moment ist digitale das einzige was uns
zur verfügung steht
und dann macht es natürlich schon sind
dass wir eine gewisse grundausstattung
haben und vielleicht müssten wir mal
überlegen ob es in deutschland in meinem
fall niedersachsen so was wie eine
definierte mindestausstattung für eine
schule gibt denn in der regel ist ja für
die ausstattung der schulträger und
nicht das land zuständig was wäre denn
da so dabei in so einer
mindestausstattung was bräuchte es dann
also das ist vieles wird jetzt auch
vorangetrieben durch den digital
parkschule aber ich finde zb einen
schulserver wichtig also dass wir alle
kinder per e mail erreichen können dann
denke ich ist es wichtig dass wir einen
starken internetanschluss also ein
glasfaseranschluss haben dann müssen wir
aber auch über andere software und
endgeräte reden und dabei dürfen wir nie
vergessen alles das was ich jetzt sage
ist im prinzip digitalisierung und das
sind gerät
also im prinzip ist das noch
technisierung wir müssen uns auch
darüber gedanken machen wie wir die
ganze technik sinnvoll
entsprechend in den unterricht und mit
den inhalten verknüpfen und das braucht
einfach ein bisschen zeit positiv
formuliert könnte man aber auch sagen
ich glaube dass wir in den letzten drei
wochen so viel neues dazugelernt haben
wir haben jetzt gelernt wenn auch aus
der not heraus was gut funktioniert und
was nicht funktioniert und ich glaube
man kann das auch so ein bisschen als
einen digitalen meilenstein bezeichnen
weil wir jetzt mit ganz ganz vielen
neuen eindrücken vielleicht neue
entscheidung treffen und wissen dass der
eine weg gut war um den sollten wir
weiter verfolgen und ein anderer weg
vielleicht ein irrweg war die wir dann
vielleicht auch beenden sollten ich
gucke hat hier noch mal in die
kommentare rein und ihr kommt eine frage
zum thema digitalisierung von dennis bei
youtube er fragt was ist denn wenn die
schule komplett ausfällt bis nach den
sommerferien können dann klausuren auch
per e-mail geschrieben werden ich
erweitere einfach mal oder gibt es
irgendeine andere digitale möglichkeit
prüfungs wissen abzufragen
ja das ist das ist immer schwierig also
wie die erste frage wer vielleicht heißt
prüfungen immer nur wissen abfragen ich
hoffe nicht
tatsächlich ist das auch eine frage die
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt noch nicht
beantworten kann ich habe die feste
hoffnung dass ich meine schüler bald
real wieder sehe ich hoffe dass wir
schnell in den schulbetrieb
zurückbekommen aber natürlich ist das
schwierig ich kann das überhaupt nicht
abschätzen
ich hoffe dass da die experten einfach
eine gute entscheidung treffen werden
und man muss einfach abwägen schule und
sicherheit das ist ganz ganz schwierig
und das kann ich als lehrer
wahrscheinlich am allerwenigsten
einschätzen
sie kommen sehr sehr viele fragen noch
zu prüfungen und auch zur fairness
ich werde mal ein paar davon vorlesen
und zwar einmal simon fragt ob sie der
meinung sind dass es fair ist schüler
unter solchen bedingungen das abitur
oder auch andere abschlussprüfung
schreiben zu lassen
ich weiß es nicht ich glaube man muss
ehrlich sagen wir alle haben so eine
situation noch nie gemacht und die
gegenfrage wäre was ist die alternative
ich denke wir müssen einfach das beste
aus der situation machen was genau das
ist kann ich noch nicht einschätzen
vielleicht nimmt man ganz bewusst
bestimmte prüfungsinhalte raus ich weiß
es nicht ich muss das ganze ich sagen
ich kann diese ich habe so eine
situation auch noch nicht erlebt ich bin
mir sicher da werden gute entscheidungen
getroffen werden und die werden wir
frühzeitig kommunizieren ich glaube
oberstes ziel muss es sein das ist für
alle beteiligten also in diesem jahr an
die abschlussschüler das ist da ihnen
keine nachteile gibt doch das ist das
wichtigste
aber da sind wir ja schon mittendrin
beim stichwort chancengleichheit das ist
ja eine große befürchtungen die viele
haben dass da manche vielleicht auch
leistungsschwächere generell
leistungsschwächere schüler auf der
strecke bleiben während die
leistungsstärkeren dann an ihnen vorbei
ziehen haben sie diese befürchtung auch
also ich glaube man muss einfach so
ehrlich sein und sagen dass jetzt diese
diese zeit einfach unterschiedlich
genutzt wird
und wenn ich zu hause in den starkes
elternhaus habe die da so ein bisschen
fokus darauf legen dann wird er
höchstwahrscheinlich mehr passieren als
in einem lassie für ihren haushalt ja
das ist einfach so ich weiß aber auch
nicht ob man das kompensieren kann oder
ob das nicht streng genommen auch in der
schulzeit sowieso immer so ist nein das
ist einfach eine situation die wird so
sein und da werden wir mit umgehen
müssen hier kommt noch eine frage von
werner bei youtube wird dieser jahrgang
bei der jobsuche nicht auch
diskriminiert werden werden wegen der
aktuellen situation wenn nein warum
nicht
ja wahrscheinlich lebt man sich ein paar
jahre hohn und spott abholen müssen
aber ich glaube das hat in der
vergangenheit wenn auch in anderer form
auch schon mal gegeben
also ich glaube nicht dass es langzeit
nachteilige kann ich mir nicht
vorstellen denn man muss ja sagen
zumindest bis vor drei wochen war es ja
so dass der arbeitsmarkt händeringend
nach leuten gesucht hat und das ist ja
kein individuelles verschulden sondern
eine eine situation die einfach da ist
mit dem man umgehen muss und ich glaube
das wird keine langzeitfolgen
aber man muss ja schon die frage stellen
wegen der versetzung die wird hier auch
gestellt von kamen bei facebook die sagt
nämlich ja wie geht es dann weiter wenn
die schule länger
dazu ist was heißt das für die
versetzung kann das nicht auch
versetzungsgefährdet sein
ja das ist
ich denke im moment im bestünde ja nur
auf die noten schaum die in der
vergangenheit entstanden sind die sind
momentan die grundlage jetzt hat man
aber auch schon von verschiedenen
stimmen aus der presse gehört ob das
sitzenbleiben in diesem jahr nicht
vielleicht grundsätzlich freiwillig sein
sollte und auf beratung zurück geht ich
glaube auch hier muss man einfach
abwarten welche entscheidung da
getroffen werden ich glaube es muss
immer ein klar sein dass solche
entscheidung immer zum wohle des
schülers getroffen werden und ich glaube
das gleiche gilt wie gerade bei den
prüfungen hier wird man gute lösung
finden da bin ich mir ganz sicher
sie haben gerade schon angesprochen
dieses freiwillig sitzen bleiben das ist
ja ein vorschlag des lehrerverbands das
eben schüler sagen können ich möchte das
ja freiwillig wiederholen
wie finden sie das dann diese idee also
im prinzip ist das ja ein mittel was wir
schon in der vergangenheit immer
angewendet haben ganz ganz häufig finden
vor den konferenzen vor dem versetzung
konferenzen gespräche statt und in der
regel ist ja den betroffenen auch klar
dass es entweder mindestens sehr knapp
wird oder dass es halt nichts wird und
dieses freiwillige wiederholen oder
freiwilliges zurücksetzen wie wir es
nennen
das gibt es eigentlich ganz ganz häufig
und ich kann mir schon gut vorstellen
dass dies zielführend ist wenn man ein
zeugnis hatte mit vielen mangelhaft oder
ungenügend dass man dann gezielt auf die
eltern zugehen und sagt hören sie zu wie
sieht's aus wollen wir da nicht
vielleicht doch wiederholen ist das
nicht der bessere weg
ich glaube dass man da zu guten
ergebnissen kommen kann hier ist noch
eine frage bei youtube die ein bisschen
oder finde ganz gut zeigt wie groß die
sorgen wirklich sind lexi schreibt das
zeugnis in diesem halbjahr ist für mich
wichtig es entscheidet ob ich zugelassen
werde auf die oberstufe nimmt die schule
rücksicht und lässt mich zu oder nichts
ja auch das ist eine frage die man
abwarten muss ich will mich dann gerne
noch mal wiederholen ich denke dass
diese zeit die wir jetzt erleben nicht
nachteilig sein wird für die für den
weitern danken
schule das wissen wir lehrer und alle
beteiligten entscheidungsträger ja auch
und ich denke man gitter im rahmen der
möglichkeiten rücksicht nehmen was aber
nicht bedeutet das natürlich einen nicht
ein mindestmaß an leistung erbracht sein
muss aber man muss eben auch die
möglichkeit gehabt haben das ganze zu
erbringen und ich denke in diesem spagat
wird sich das bewegen und jetzt
vielleicht eine frage die passt ganz gut
da können wir in kleinen ausblick
vielleicht machen weil es geht ja auch
darum wie wird die schule wieder
geöffnet wir wissen es noch nicht ganz
genau wann ist der zeitpunkt wird aber
es könnte ja auch sein dass es so eine
schrittweise öffnung gibt und hier fragt
michelle bei youtube ganz passend wie
kann denn der mindestabstand in schulen
eingehalten werden gibt es das schon in
die ideen die die schulen so ja im
stillen kämmerlein für sich schon mal
sich überlegen wo sie schüler verteilen
können gibt so was ich glaube das ist
ein ganz ganz schwieriges thema ich
glaube die frage die man sich stellen
muss
egal welcher organisationsform angibt ob
man jetzt nur jeden zweiten klassenraum
besetzt oder ob man sowas wie vormittags
und nachmittagsunterricht macht oder
einfach die graben klassen an den tag
die ungeraden klassen
letztlich hängt alles aus meiner sicht
von der disziplin der schüler abschaffen
es junge heranwachsende sich wirklich
dazu benehmen diese anderthalb oder zwei
meter abstand zu halten
das funktioniert alles nur wenn die
schüler verstanden haben worum es geht
dass das kann ein lehrer weil ich sag
mal drei oder 500 schülern gar nicht
überblicken das wird schwierig also da
geht es einfach um die
verantwortungsbereitschaft der schüler
herr schmidt ich bedanke mich ganz
herzlich viele fragen wie kann man
einfach jetzt noch nicht beantworten das
ist klar aber sie haben auch einige
tipps glaube ich den auch den schülern
und den eltern gegeben die heute
zugeschaut haben danke dafür gerne und
ich bedanke mich auch bei euch fürs zu
sehen
kommende woche ist hier wieder daniel
bröckerhoff für euch da und ich sagt
tschüss
[Musik]
und wenn euch diese sprechstunde
gefallen hat dann interessiert euch
vielleicht auch diese hier
da haben wir mit harald lesch über die
zukunft nach corona gesprochen oder die
hier da hat einen faktencheck corona
fakes widerlegt oder ihr lasst hier ein
abo da und was immer eine gute idee ist
die neue zdf heute app aktualisieren
dies nämlich jetzt ganz neu